now this video isn't going to go live
until sometime after i shoot it but i
hope you folks appreciate
i am in three layers and i am shooting
this in the middle of summer
[Music]
under the lake so yeah
another two-parter there are a lot this
series
which i mean i kind of admire it's weird
coming off of a series that previously
had no two-parters except for the finale
it gives it this weird feel of
experimental but not like ooh let's try
something different but more like oh
well
people were kind of torn on the last one
let's do like nearly the opposite
that doesn't seem like a decision driven
by artistic intent
more by throw some more stuff with the
wall anyways
the first half of two-parter that i've
always liked
but i have not revisited in a while and
certainly
gets mentioned a lot whenever people in
my comment section bring up
underrated stories not that i think
people bash it too much but it doesn't
get
mentioned all that often and judging by
first half alone
folks might be onto something i think it
may be underrated in a similar way to
how the rebel flesh and the almost
people is underrated in that
there's a lot more going on for it than
people give a credit for not like
absolute top tier but like upper half of
the middle at the
bare minimum like worthy of of good
conversation to be had about it
so first off this one it got in my good
graces right
off the bat because it's clear
immediately that it's a base under siege
story
and i love base under siege stories i
don't know why
i just think it's a format that really
suits doctor who always has base under
siege was like the standard for the
second doctor back in the day
and it still plays well even now i think
so
it's a nice clean setup you lock the
doctor in a
in a place there's monsters in that
place try and save the people who were
in that place before the doctor got
there
nice simple straightforward now we've
got the introduction of ghosts now this
is not the first time that modern era
doctor who has given us
fake ghosts but i do feel like it leans
into it a little bit more here because
like we look at something like the gel
from series one or sword of the siren
was ghost like
but there's something nice that it just
goes whole hog on this one
or also hide that was there was
ghostliness going on there
but i i like that this just has these
things with these
big hollow dead eyes just wandering
around
yeah that's unsettling and that the
rules are slightly different that they
can pick up and interact with metal
things which means they can grab
weapons oh crap
so that's a nice touch as far as that
goes we've got a nice uh
cast for the folks in the base um
a good group of interesting characters
and the least interesting one
is the first one to get killed off well
second one to be killed off because
the captain gets killed in the cold open
do captains
ever survive these base under siege
situations
i feel like whoever is in charge never
makes it
the only time i could think of like
maybe the impossible plan of the satan
pit
though to be fair he was acting captain
because the actual captain died before
the story even started
i think being in command just don't plan
on making it to retirement age
not if you're in a doctor who's story
and aside from the very introduction of
the ghosts and figure out how they work
there's actually a genuinely well-built
mystery here in terms of trying to
figure out how these things work what
the rules are and the planting of things
like the letters and that one shot we
get
of the characters you know where it's
reflected in their eye
enough attention is drawn to it that
you're like oh okay but not like super
see this this is what's going on i feel
like it's well balanced there
and you find yourself catching things
like the fact that
one of the crew members has not been
inside
and you know that'll pay off a bit later
but it's it's just a well put together
structure and series of reveals and
things that we figure out
as it goes along it's pretty nicely put
together and there's some decent tension
in it
there's also some interesting and for me
some like
i don't know about that things going on
with the doctor and clara
specifically so starting with clara
at the very beginning of the episode she
is very
excited about being in danger which is
a little bit different from how the
companions often behave
we've had we've seen before where the
companions get very excited about what
they might
encounter and when they encounter
something that looks like ooh that's
unusual
maybe it's dangerous they get a little
excited but i don't recall them being
flat out excited by the idea of being
in danger which clara seems to have at
the opening
of this and i feel like that's kind of
important
especially given where things are going
to go with her a bit later on
in addition to that the doctor's
starting to recognize that she's
for lack of a better term trying to be
like him
and he's telling her flat out don't
don't do that
and of course that's going to pay off
very directly a couple episodes down the
line
so i'm finding myself feeling
a bit intrigued and odd about
where i know things are going because
i hate hellbent i hate it
but i'm realizing that at least part of
the groundwork
is fairly decently laid out
i'll probably explain this a bit better
later on i feel like it was laid out for
something that they
that the this series does and then the
it keeps going and it overshoots
but it is laying the groundwork for this
level that clara's taking things to of
her
getting too into the danger of her
trying to approach things
like the doctor and knowing what that's
going to cause to happen in face the
raven
the groundwork is legitimately being
laid it's not being pulled from its butt
now the whole hybrid thing is still
really pulled from the shows but but we
will tackle that eventually
when we get to it there is one moment
with the doctor though that throws me
off and that's the thing with the cards
i get what it's doing but it's
it's ham-fisted like there's already
enough things to establish him as being
a little bit awkward around
these people that we don't need
something to hammer the point home like
that
like honestly just him going back and
forth with his
they're not ghosts they're not ghosts
they're ghosts and getting all excited
about that and just people looking at
him like
what we established that he is not
communicating well with basically anyone
who isn't clara the cards
just are making the same point that was
already being made organically by the
story
i don't like them it's not that i
dislike the point they're making it's
that it's a clunky way to make a point
that was already being made
so no don't do that the doctor does have
some other really good moments though
again
nicely contradictory moments you know
little moments when he's trying to
figure out what's going on it's
impossible i hate it it's evil it's
astonishing i want to kiss it to death
like i love that moment
that's a terrific moment now the
um the whole thing with the teaser at
the end
i have mixed feelings about it's okay i
remember some people bringing this up as
like why didn't i put this on my
greatest
clift cliffhangers thing is because i
don't feel that it's a good cliffhanger
the whole thing of seeing the doctor as
a ghost
i think it's a very good tease for the
next it's a good hook in
i don't think it works well as a
cliffhanger though because
you don't need to know what happens to
note well he's not actually going to die
so for me there's no tension there's no
threat in that
and if there's no tension then it's not
a proper cliffhanger it's still a good
note to end on it's a solid tease i just
don't think it has
a ton of value as an actual cliffhanger
so
you know it's fine i actually kind of
feel like i don't have that much more to
say with this one
um unlike say magician's apprentice and
which is familiar which had a lot more
packed into each half
that you know i could devote time to
this really is just half of a story
and i have to see the other half to
have more thoughts to say about it but
it is a good
solid well put together intriguing
tense base under siege first half of a
two-parter
it's solid the complications work the
introduction of the day night cycle
which is then
something that can be thrown off to make
them in danger when they thought they
were safe there's
it's nicely constructed in terms of the
complications and everything going on
they find
a nice organic way to split the split
the party
and so clara is stuck on the base with
these
uh two other people while the doctor
goes back in time to try and figure out
what's going on and try to stop it
so it builds the the situation well
leads us into our next story and um
guess i got nothing left to say except
let's get to the next one
under the lake have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it usual stuff to do
like comment share subscribe bell
patreon
of course that is what is currently
keeping these lights that i am melting
under
on right now so any assistance you can
lend there is greatly appreciated but
you also don't have to because
at the end of the day you are the
council and i just run the meetings
so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
um
[Music]